when you exercise that creativity muscle
you're able to come up with experiments
how can I experiment to improve this
aspect of my knowledge or life or
whatever so for instance with comedy
again I was having a hard time coming up
with one-liners like I'm a public
speaker for a long time so that means
I'm good at storytelling and humorous
storytelling but coming up with
one-liners it's one sentence that gets
people to laugh that wasn't an expertise
of mine so here's an experiment I did it
took a half hour I went onto a subway
and every stop I moved from car to car
in the subway and I would do stand-up
comedy in the subway and now no other
person sitting in the subway wanted to
hear me do it so it was really difficult
it was really out of my comfort zone
it's gotta be a little uncomfortable
because no one's ever done it before so
it's got to be uncomfortable and I had
to really tighten up my jokes super hard
to get anybody to laugh and that was an
experiment that helped me improve my
one-liners and by the way it also became
a story I could tell or a story I could
write about
one of the things that I was talking
about recently was with an ex Marines
officer from the UK and he was talking
about his time over in Afghanistan and
he was a Somalia pirate hunter Somali
pirate hunter was like his second of
career after he left left work in
Afghanistan and he was talking about
just how different life is out there and
he said he was talking about singing the
praises of travel and new experiences
and what you've suggested to there about
the idea generation and how important it
is is you kind of don't really know what
you like until yet until you you try to
do something and our sample size the
sample size of experiences that were
working with is so it's such a fraction
of the total potential number of
experiences that you could have as a
human right like unless you try
something how do you know what you do I
don't like it right like people often
think to themselves that they could
think they can think their way to their
passion there's no way to figure out
what your passion is with just your
brain you have to do things that there's
no thinking you have to actually do in
order to know and that's critical that's
why that's why travel is interesting if
you're if you're the sort of person who
benefits a lot from travel or you know
if you enjoy traveling travel to as many
places as possible to see where you like
what you like to do what you like to do
in each place for me I like to
experiment with of these different ideas
because again I'm not gonna know until I
do something I'm not gonna know what
it's like to write like I could think of
a great plot in my head for a novel but
I'm not gonna know what it's like to
write a novel unless I sit down and
write it I'm sorry to interrupt this
very important distinction because it's
the difference between learning
something in school and in the real
world because in school no matter what
you do the thing you're most learning is
the thing you're most learning in a
classroom it our classroom skills you
could only learn real-world skills in
the real world there's no other way one
of the things I've been thinking about
recently we're at the start of the new
year new decades new year's goals how do
I
relate about 25 year vision to my
five-year Reebok to my 1 year
medium-term goals to my daily habits and
routines and blah blah blah so I've kind
of been swimming in the the masturbatory
world of personal development for the
last little while just because I I do
quite like to look at that sort of stuff
and I speak to a lot of the guys on this
podcast and I'm certainly one of the
things that it appears to be there is
quite a top-down approach to how you
should experiment with your life
that getting distracted by shiny things
and pivoting as it's called that's like
that's the the Silicon Valley term for
it right it's like you can pivot with
your particular brand direction or your
particular goals should only be done at
the end of particular review periods
because you don't know whether or not
you've squeezed everything out of the
lemon in the interim but the problem
with that is a lot of passions are
emergent not dictated you know like your
passions in life aren't I thought of
this thing and then I'll think about how
to do the plan and the dis that and the
other I could think it would be [ __ ]
great to do a podcast which I did two
years ago but it wasn't until I did the
podcast that as I oh this is actually
really really cool get to talk to a lot
of interesting people this is the sort
of thing I want to do and then stupidly
at the start of last year I decided to
lynchpin myself to a twice a week
publishing schedule but not and now I
want to do that and now I'm not how can
I do three shall start in YouTube videos
should I start doing short form content
and blah blah blah but I don't know
until I do that and I do think a lot of
the time we consider I certainly know
that I do and the listeners might do as
well I consider the barriers not
necessarily the barriers to entry but
kind of like the skill set that I need
or the amount of planning and
understanding that I need in order to be
able to get an idea moving so oh well
you know let you the Trump thing right a
trump card thing yeah right well if I
sit down if I if I knock the back end of
this week off and I don't go away this
weekend I could maybe sit down and begin
to do a plan about what the brand name
might be and then once it's so
pedestrian and so slow whereas it seems
like you're just pants off gear out jump
into the pool feet first Here I am yeah
this is what we're doing
yeah well some things though are hard
like let's say from the podcast you want
to say well I'm gonna also make it big
on YouTube YouTube videos that really
work in the YouTube channels that really
work require a lot more production value
than a podcast usually to succeed and
let's say succeeding means you know
getting a million views on on a YouTube
video and mate and it also requires some
consistency you might have a high
production value for 50 videos in a row
without any success
and then the 51st video becomes wildly
successful because you've started to
find your voice on YouTube and and after
that it's it's all systems go and you
might say to yourself you know you might
this is where you may think okay that's
not an experiment I'm willing to try
because I'm not that into it
or it doesn't excite me that much yeah
sure it'd be great to be have about 50
million YouTube subscribers but I just
don't want to put the time in right now
because I'm enjoying the time I'm doing
on other things so a lot of the
experiments I described I figure out to
make money some of those don't you kind
of experiment on what will make money
what doesn't and like I always think of
myself man I wish I did add more
presence on YouTube and I try I
experiment a little but I can see it or
is gonna require more effort then um
then my personal compass is telling me
to put in that said I just started
experimenting with tick tock which is
totally different and I'm kind of
enjoying the creativity on tick tock and
so I don't really care how many
followers are you get or how many views
I get it's just kind of fun and so so if
I have a few free moments I might try
another tick tock video or something
because it doesn't really require as
much as much effort as much production
value to create a decent tick tock video
these low friction low time and resource
investment ideas seem to be the sort of
thing that's quite fun to play around
with I have to say you know quite
embarrassingly
I am despite being a businessman slash
entrepreneur of one kind or another for
the last 13 years
I am certainly in the camp that I
described one maybe moves quite sort of
pedestrian Li with things very
considered
it's an attention to detail but it's
just it's borderline just like neurotic
and and and and very restricting when it
comes to things like that I certainly
think if I was um you know if I was able
to move a little bit more towards that
expedited look let's this it's an idea
it's an idea just have a crack at an
idea maybe we like to do salsa dancing I
wonder what it would be like if I learn
to public speaker and I just [ __ ] go
to a class like don't think about it
don't research we had the best class
like just go to the class
yeah totally like a couple years ago I
was I took a bunch of ping pong lessons
by the way and I you could get good at
spin I potentially I was already pretty
good but I wanted to get better and I
took classes and other things and then I
wanted to also this was gonna be the
year I was gonna sit down and write a
novel I've written a lot of non-fiction
books I hadn't written a novel and then
one day I went up on stage and did
stand-up comedy at a comedy club and I
loved it and so if I had made myself a
goal this year I'm doing a novel and
nothing's gonna get in the way and I'm
not gonna be distracted by shiny objects
I never would have tried stand-up comedy
and I love doing it and it was a
difficult skill to learn but I decided
you know what I love this so much like
my cup my inner compass is telling me
this is a direction to go so I said okay
no novel and I'm just gonna focus on
this and it's like five years later I'm
still you know actually I'm headlining
at a major Club in New York City this
weekend so you know thank you it's
incredible yeah and so your inner
compass kind of tells you which
directions to go and I gave up the
ping-pong classes I gave up some other
things I was trying gave up writing the
novel and focus on this on this one
thing without it hurting my business I
run an entire business without hurting
my business so cuz you know stand-up
comedy's at night and at businesses
during the day
I think again having looked at the the
productivity world and the listeners
will be familiar with this that they say
your true calling in life is at the
intersection of what you're good at what
you love to do what you can be paid for
and what society needs and trying to
create this Venn diagram and map on this
sort of weird polygon with all of the
different attributes of whatever it is
that you do and blah blah it does feel
like kind of putting the cart before the
horse a little bit with this stuff it's
like look like if yes if you just do the
thing if you just make the experiment
reality will reflect back to you whether
or not it's a good idea your visceral a
2-day experience of it will tell you
whether or not you enjoy it the success
that you have in it will tell you
whether or not you're any good at it
right because because think about like
let's take that Greenland experiment I
did I did earlier the world didn't need
me to do it and I wasn't necessarily
good at it you don't really know
anything until you start doing it and
there's result you get some feedback and
you in the feedbacks good enough that
you're like oh I want to keep doing it
look Here I am five years in to become
anything the world certainly doesn't
need me telling jokes to them and the
world has not decided yet to pay me for
it so it's a matter of you don't really
you don't really know what that Venn
diagram looks like until you're already
there and then so you just have to kind
of like try things and follow your heart
and this doesn't mean quit your job and
only do things you love it but but it
does mean experiment a lot experiment
and some things that make money right
away experiment and some things that
might make money ten years in the future
by the way it's the intersection of all
of your interests where you'll probably
find you make the most amount of money
in the end so you have to have though
interest that you get good at to have an
intersection to those things until you
even know what's gonna happen at that
intersection it's a unique offering
isn't it
you know this is one of the one of the
things that I think about the totality
of our experience and as you get old you
know just I'm 31 and 32
and I'm getting to the stage now where
I'm able to actually genuinely say that
I have like a curated list of different
different interests because like at 25
you just get ragged around by life it's
like oh I found myself in a ping-pong
club and then one time I fell into a
swimming pool and I swam for a bit like
you did the range the broadness of your
perspective of life experiences there's
not I don't feel like you have enough
time to be able to piece together well
this is a commonality between this and
this and oh [ __ ] I actually know a guy
that is a chef in a secret restaurant
who actually plays ping pong on a
weekend and does this like you know I
it's now starting to at least piece
together where I can see some of the
commonalities between these different
things and interestingly actually did an
exercise today that was working out my
core values which I've never done before
and I found that to be really
interesting to try and look back at what
are the different things all of the all
the different stuff that I enjoy in life
was involved with one of these five core
values it was really interesting yeah
and and and you know again what happens
is is that trying different things
you're gonna if you get good or even
mildly good even mediocre at like a
bunch of different things that you've
been experimenting with you never know
when the intersection of those things
turns into something huge even if this
the pieces never made money for you or
never got huge but but if everything's
aligned with your core values so that
means the intersection should be aligned
with your core values it's gonna it's
gonna work out somehow at the
intersection so for instance thirty
years ago I started writing every day I
didn't make us I didn't make a single
dime on writing until 11 years 12 years
later and I didn't make significant
money on writing until maybe three or
four years after that and but also
during that time you know about 20 years
ago I started investing professionally
and at first I was very bad at it and
then I and then I learned I came up with
ideas to learn and get better and better
and better and better and more and more
knowledgeable because I had a very
untraditional path towards investing
like I wasn't an MB I never studied it I
had to really learn everything on my own
and after about 10 after about this
years of that I combined my writing with
my investing skill and experience and I
by that point I had vast experience
investing in knowledge and I created an
investment newsletter and that made me a
significant amount of money so that made
me far more money than investing ever
made me and that made me far more money
than writing ever made me actually buy
now investing has caught up and made me
more but at the time writing an
investment related course made me a
significant amount of money to unique
offering right who else yeah is there
that has that particular blend of
experiences it's one of the things that
I the nuance that I struggle with with
all of this is the Explorer exploit
paradigm again so it's like look I don't
follow
I don't for instance my favorite podcast
was Joe Rogan one of the reasons I
listened damn is because as far as
greats and he's the best on the planet
at asking is the best man on the planet
at asking questions I don't follow
someone who is one-tenth as good as Joe
Rogan but also has nine of the things
that he is one-tenth as good at Joe
Rogan ah as well so what I'm saying is
we follow people who are at the absolute
peak within their engine or we tend to
follow people who are the very best
within each individual section and I
know that there would be some people who
would say well it's all well and good
saying that you're gonna experiment and
you can play around with shiny things
but you're gonna get out competed by the
person who has one fewer thing to do
than you do and dedicate the same
proportion of their time to it way but
let's say you know let's say you know
you found your Joe Rogan's your favorite
for an interview podcast so let's say
someone came along who was a better
interviewer than Joe Rogan you probably
wouldn't switch from Joe Rogan to this
other guy because you like Joe Rogan and
you like his style and you got to know
his story through whitewashing hundreds
of his podcasts but let's say now there
was a great podcast that was a they were
telling a serial story about a murder
mystery and you know they would call
people and it was a real real true crime
telling people if you listened
up and vanished James oh no oh man no
it's a good up and vanished is my it's
it's quite it's like maybe three or four
years old the guy Payne Lindsay the guy
that created it is just out of this
world this is a real life ten-year-old
missing person inquiry that had gone
cold and pain Lindsay this guy's just
like ah I just fancy starting a podcast
about this this thing and starts doing
it and then is investigating week on
week as he's releasing episode so he's
iterating live releasing an episode
about what happened in the last week
then there's a discussion forum then he
starts doing live Q&A s then he gets
like legal experts in to do extra
episodes in between these ones where
they'll review the evidence the case
evidence and then at the end of season
one which remember this is wasn't
planned this isn't like some sort of
storyline with a [ __ ] arc at the end
of season one they're going to trial
wow man I'll link you to it once we're
finished it is phenomenal but yes so but
this is a great example what I'm talking
about like I'm assuming that guy is a
very good interviewer because he's able
to interview enough to talk to witnesses
and other people possibly involved in
the crime and so on so he's a good
interviewer but he probably said to
himself you know what I don't want to do
an interview podcast it's already Joe
Rogan there's already other people out
there doing that even if I was better
than them nobody really knows if I'm
better or not nobody could tell the
difference between 20 percent better and
and 20 percent worse so I'm not gonna do
that I'm gonna do something completely
different
you can't you can't succeed by just
being better you have to be different
also so so that was the way he thought
about doing a podcast and that was the
right approach like man that's why he's
much if he had just done an interview
podcast he'd be like the other 500,000
interview podcasts yeah so what we've
kind of swam around here is what we
discussed before the podcast something
that I think you've been thinking about
a fair bit recently although I get the
impression that you think about a lot of
different things as well so this may be
like an eon away from you now but am i
right in thinking that you're working on
how you can jump the queue with progress
in life at the moment yeah because yeah
so we live in like you you mentioned
before like we're
we're having because of this world of
abundance possibly there's this
opportunity for an existential crisis
like why are we here what should we do
and I don't think we're having that like
just because there's less you know
factory jobs doesn't mean we're
struggling with our purpose in life most
people didn't really want to work in the
factory anyway but I do think that the
life is complex enough that we're
switching careers and passions and
interests very often in our life so I
probably switched careers twelve
different times in my life and I'll
probably switch at 12 different times
again who knows and you always have to
say well but wait I'm 40 I'm 45 or I'm
60 or I'm 70 how am I gonna possibly get
started on playing golf now I'm never
gonna be the best golf player in the
world so so a you have to you have to
figure out well what's what's the
metrics for success in my new interest
like why do I want to do this and not
not as a goal but just like how do I
determine if I'm making progress or do I
want progress and then if you do want
progress there's always a hierarchy
there are people who are the worst and
there are people who are the best and
there's a hierarchy from from first to
last so if you wanted to write a book
sure you could write a book and never
publish it or you could write a book and
self publish it and have no sales or you
could write a book self publish it have
lots of sales we're gonna write a book
and get huge advances and sell millions
of copies and so on so you have to kind
of decide where in the hierarchy you
know you you you kind of want to be and
then no matter what it is unless it's
like you know you're seven years old and
you want to be a professional basketball
player which is you have to be realistic
also but let's say you have realistic
metrics then you have to decide
everyone's going to tell you you're too
old or you've got to do this for 20
years at least or the 10,000 hour rule
you got to do it for 10,000 hours before
you're in the top 1% of whatever
hierarchy you're joining whether it's
professional this or professional
ping-pong or whatever comedy and comedy
and and my theory is is that the 10,000
hour rule only works for very repetitive
tasks like memorizing strings of numbers
for
since or playing the piano which has of
course there's artistic component I
playing the piano but a lot of it is
repetitive just playing over and over
again the same pieces and that's how you
learn and you get feedback you do you
get feedback from an instructor and then
you play it again you get feedback you
play it again but my theory is you could
skip the line with what what I call the
10000 experiment role which is and
there's various types of experiments you
could do that are better than others but
essentially every time you do an
experiment in in the area that you're
interested in you'll learn something
you'll get better and you'll also start
differentiating yourself and finding
your own unique way of doing something
that's different from everyone else so
for instance you know with with with
comedy there's a British comedian who I
admire a lot name's Chris Turner and he
as what I call he has skipped the line
so what he did was he's been doing
stand-up comedy he's 27 years old so
nobody would say nobody in the comedy
world would traditionally say oh he's 27
years old doing comedy he should be that
is you know starring in every comedy
club in the world no he's they would say
no he's got to do it a few more years
but he also if you give him five
completely random words he will do the
most within seconds of thinking about it
he will do the most amazing freestyle
rap on the fly
it'll be an rap won't just be like
rhyming the words he'll it'll be so
intelligent and so funny and he just
made it up and and I've seen him do it
with five random words like I came up
with the random words and he just did it
right there and now he's performs in any
comedy club in the world that he wants
to because he's he's not just a stand-up
comedian he also has this other skill he
differentiated himself he skipped the
line because he experimented with
combining his interest in rapping with
stand-up comedy and that's given him
this unique voice in the stand-up comedy
world nobody else on the planet does
that like he does and and particularly
as intelligently as he does like even if
someone else rapped they can't do it as
intelligently as he does he's super
smart and so you know that's an example
and so for me I've been able to skip the
line somewhat instead of like I said I'm
I'm headlining at a Caroline's on
Broadway on Saturday I've been able to
skip the line because in part I've made
it a lifelong effort to learn how to
learn so I could pick up lots of
different interests and learn very
quickly so I would start to use that
technique on comedy and then I combined
my podcast with that where I had some of
the best comedians in the world on my
podcast and so I'm able to ask them any
question I want like I'll think about
the difficulties I've been having the
past week in comedy and let's say I have
this world famous comedian on I'll say
well what if this this this and this
happened to you
what would you do and now nobody else
gets that opportunity to ask the top
comedians very specific situations about
how they would respond I've gotten I've
every time they answer a question like
that it's like I skip months and months
or years of learning and whatever it is
I'm asking and you know and then I've
had other opportunities like that that
you know as helped me skip the line
quite a bit other some principles or
some foundations to skipping the line
the universal or be universally helpful
so I can think of some one of them would
probably be having some form of a
platform online or some kind of
notoriety that allows you to reach
people you know that's enabled you to do
certain things we get better podcast
guests you know get when you release and
GoFundMe to try and buy great learn to
garner a little bit of media attention
which you then kind of become self
perpetuating and blah blah you mentioned
about your ability learning to learn and
stuff like that are there any other sort
of foundational elements to this well I
think foundational is come exercising
their creativity muscle and keeping the
rest of your lives
healthy emotional physical and so on but
when you exercise that creativity muscle
you're able to come up with experiments
what can i how can I experiment to
improve this aspect of my knowledge or
life or whatever so for instance with
comedy again I was having a hard time
coming up with one-liners like I'm a
public speaker for a long time so that
means I'm good at storytelling and
humorous storytelling but come
with one-liners it's one sentence that
gets people to laugh that wasn't an
expertise of mine so what I did was
here's an experiment I did it took a
half hour I went onto a subway you know
an underground train you know a subway
and an every stop I moved from car to
car in the subway and I would do
stand-up comedy in the subway and now no
other person sitting in the subway
wanted to hear me do it was really
difficult it was really out of my
comfort zone you have to be a little out
of your comfort zone it's gotta be a
little uncomfortable because no one's
ever done it before so it's got to be
uncomfortable and I had to really
tighten up my jokes super hard to get to
get anybody to laugh and that was an
experiment that helped me improve my
one-liners and by the way it also became
a story I could tell or a story I could
write about and in fact I expanded it
even further I I created the entire
format of a late night TV show and I had
on a guest I had on a musical guest all
in the subway you know audience
participation where I'd interview people
sitting in the subway because I was
starting it really comfortable with
talking with people on the subway yeah
and so and you know that experiment
didn't really work in the sense that I
you know I put up a video of my my
late-night talk show in the subway
format and you know I could have kept
doing that and made it like a real show
but I didn't really want to but at least
it was an experiment I had to study the
late night format I had to get get
better at one-liners again not great
because you'll never be great down there
and and it was fun and then I have a
story to tell from it and look if that
first one was huge that would have been
a different story mm-hmm it's um the the
the main thing that I've got in my mind
is for the listeners I'm gonna break the
fourth wall for a second Jameses sound
guy the guy that sets up his sound is
called Jay and all I've got in the back
of my mind when you're talking about
this subway thing is the nightmare that
sound guy Jay would have with capturing
clean audio yes I'm just thinking like
Jays Jays gonna have to like James has
decided to have this idea and poor Jays
they're looking along an entire sound
desk in a desperate attempt to try and
the sound of the subways wheels on metal
I mean the good thing is though you get
a caption so we caption things and had
mics on and and so on but it was again
it was a fun because I did videotape it
because that's the other thing too is
you want to be able to have some way of
measuring your experiment so for
instance when I do comedy i videotape it
so I could watch it later I try to do
that every time I don't always do it but
I try to do it because you have to be
able to measure your progress but uh
again like with with anything like even
with a podcast so I do to interview
podcasts a week with with guests usually
guests who are somewhat celebrities
famous whatever but I'm experimenting
with format too
so I'm trying I'm about to start trying
a format that instead of it being an
hour or two hours it's 15 minutes where
I just tell a little story and maybe
there's a co-host who's just asked basic
questions and then in 15-20 minutes it's
done
so actually we just did one it was a
little more than 15 minutes but I had
never done this before I ran the whole
Iran situation happened over the weekend
so Sunday I call I wanted to know more
and I assumed my audience wanted to know
more so I called up a top military
intelligence official I got the complete
breakdown about what was happening and I
ran that the very next day on Monday and
I had never done anything like that was
an experiment I never done that before
and that will be my most downloaded
episode in the past two months Wow how
cool is that
yeah that's awesome yeah the short film
thing on audio was really interesting I
was having a discussion with Matt from
podcast notes who I know will be
listening and I I couldn't work I like
it's such a wild west at the moment with
this but I can totally see a place for
it you know like Navarre was doing those
three minute long podcasts that was a
part of his how it get rich without
getting lucky the series I mean like who
listens to these three minute podcast
but then at the end of it when he
creates a three and a half hour
omnibus collage thing of them all you're
actually at all
kind of makes a bit of sense so we talk
yeah we talked about skipping the line
we've talked about the fact that
experimenting is an important part of
that what else why else have you been
thinking about to do with skipping the
line recently well another thing that's
important is to you know whenever you're
in a line or whatever you're trying to
succeed it's something as I mentioned
earlier there's a hierarchy there's
there's the worst going all the way up
to the best the best all that going all
the way down the worst and the best
tends to look down at the worst and
whatever you know where you are in the
hierarchy were primates primates tend to
know where they where they are in the
hierarchy the benefit of being human is
we could diversify our hierarchies as
opposed to being stuck in one tribe but
you know there's all sorts of
interesting techniques so for instance
what if you're trying to succeed at
something but you take a step back and
take a lower job become the big fish in
a smaller pond but that allows you to
then skip four steps forward when
because you become known as the best in
this smaller pond so a friend of mine
was a lawyer and he finished his law
degree and he wanted to be in the CIA
and in the Central Intelligence Agency
and he he couldn't for whatever reason
so he took an internship usually set
aside for people still in their
undergrad years like the first or second
year underground here he was a lawyer he
went to grad school got a law degree
whatever he took an internship with the
Secret Service and they were like what
do you the Secret Service the Secret
Service is the part of the White House
that protects the president and it's
like the guard and they were like why do
you want to be in the internship program
that's only for teenagers you're already
a lawyer and he's like don't worry about
it I'm really interested so they let him
in and because he was a lawyer he was
able to deliver legal documents to the
president occasionally and in order to
do that he had to get top-secret
clearance so now he's the only intern
ever who has top-secret clearance so he
uses that too suddenly
get a job at I think it was actually I
think was maybe the FBI oversee I forget
the exact details but he got a job at
the internship program for the CIA
because nobody in the internship program
there had top-secret clearance and was a
lawyer and then using that in his spare
time he would list it around he would
look for what are opportunities oh his
boss's boss's boss was looking for some
potential terrorists he tracked he had
time he tracked the person down so now
he pleased his boss's boss's boss this
guy said who are you
well I'm an intern I'm an intern but I
happen to be the only intern with
top-secret clearance and I'm a lawyer so
he got quickly promoted up through the
CIA so he moved much faster he skipped a
line right where he wanted to be at the
CIA by taking two steps backward each
time and that's another interesting
technique is to keep your ego out of it
sometimes you got to take two steps
backward to succeed four steps forward
such a good story I wonder how much do
you think that he had that perfect plan
at the time because you know with
hindsight with the benefit of hindsight
it sounds like the most masterful idea
in history I don't know if he had that
plan in time although I will ask him and
but I've known other people who have
done similar things it always seems to
be a pretty good technique that works
like uh you know Ryan holiday and Ryan
holidays books so right holidays a great
writer he's written several New York
Times bestsellers his last book
stillness is the key was number one on
the New York Times bestseller list came
out a few months ago but he started off
he quit college and he started off he
just wanted to be an apprentice
he helped he helped the author Robert
Greene do research so Robert Greene
wrote 48 laws of power and some other
great books he simply did was like a
research assistant for Robert Greene but
he did really well at that and then
Robert Greene recommended to another
company that Ryan should be their head
of you know uh you know help run
marketing he ended up being so good at
that he became the head of marketing but
then he took another step back he became
intern for another writer he learned a
lot he became he he started helping Tim
Ferriss with his marketing because it's
combination of writing internships with
you know marketing experience
he helped embarrass and then suddenly he
wrote a book he knew all the right
agents he knew how to market it he knew
how to distribute it and his books
became bestsellers so you know that was
a great case of moving a couple steps
backward to achieve his goal
he's a chitlin Robert yes a past past
modern wisdom guest and he's a fantastic
guy as well I mean that is one baptism
of fire I can imagine especially seeing
the size of Robert Greene's books like
48 laws of power and the 30 hours long I
think it's inaudible something like
probably yeah Luke Tom and a half so
this I can just imagine like a poor
young slightly spotty Ryan holiday like
running around going and getting like
going into dusty shelves getting stuff
down off the library yeah and and he
learned a lot like and you could see the
results of Robert Greene's teaching and
the way Ryan puts together books so it's
a it's a it's a great technique I mean
for me I worked at a television company
HBO and I might go I wanted to make TV
shows but I couldn't get a job making TV
shows for HBO I had no experience so I
took a job as a junior software
programmer for HBO I was just in the Sun
in the IT department the software
department and but my foot was in the
door so I pitched to them hey why don't
we make an original web show for the
internet and they said of course that's
a great idea and so then I took that
original web show I showed how much
traffic it was getting and I used it to
pitch an actual TV show and they gave me
money to shoot it as a pilot so again
that was my that was my way of skipping
the line like I was the only programmer
ever in the IT department to be shooting
a pilot for HBO is an idea that I've had
recently so I'm starting to do some
productivity and leadership coaching
within some companies once in Germany
ones in actually in New York so
hopefully I'll be over later this year
and one of the ideas I've been thinking
about to just speak to new clients and
to kind of just learn what it's like to
give a speech to a room
happen to the massive amount of public
speaking was I was thinking of just cold
emailing a bunch of big businesses who
have high-powered sales floor
exacts you know like real real sort of
go-getter companies I'm just saying look
join me to come in and just give a
one-hour presentation on how everybody
in this office can be more productive if
they use a few tools and go about it
with a couple of different different
approaches to the way that they view
their productivity and I was thinking
about that and I thought well that's
that kind of sucks like I value my time
at more than 0 pounds per hour but on
the flip side of that after doing a few
of those even if no one books me even if
no one decides to get coaching off me
I'll I've got a shitload of experience
and I've got some cool stories and maybe
the boss will need a guided there's a
podcast in a couple of months time and
whatever whatever yeah I don't think
that's all I don't think there's a bad
idea I think one step easier and maybe
better we'll see is study the company
study what they might be what maybe they
could do better do do your ten ideas
thing and say oh here's ten ideas to
improve your sales at this company I'm
not charging anything I'm happy to come
in and talk to you guys or not but
here's ten ideas I I'm a customer of
your company and I really love your
products but I see where things could be
a little better here's ten ideas you
could just have for free and they're
uniquely cater to you knock yourselves
out see you later
and just give for free and you know what
will happen is some of them are gonna
respond to you and say hey we'd love for
you to come in and see what we're up to
and maybe talk to us more about this you
know if you write if you write 20 emails
like that three or four will certainly
respond and say hey why don't you come
in and hang out a little and and and
we'll just talk about this you had a
really interesting example on impact
Theory where you were talking about how
there's quite a lot of friction even
when someone thinks that they're doing
something nice and they say to you like
I think your example was hey James I
could love to come and be your intern
but then there's actually a whole load
of work attached to you like you've got
to find this this intern what what do
you what are you good at what do you
want me to do what do you going to do do
you clean the floor D check the emails
do you respond to the Facebook's or
whatever whereas you're like look if you
go to someone and you're like look ready
here's ten ideas of how I can help you
do you want me to help you yeah oh yeah
exactly
like if you don't give them homework
like if they if you say I could come in
and speak to you they got to arrange
that now and instead I wouldn't even say
here's ten ideas I could do for you I
would say here's just ten ideas to make
your life better
or make your job better or make your
sales better whatever see you later
nice nice knowing you and some people
will respond like occasionally I get
that occasionally some people somebody
will send me hey I think here's ten ways
your your website could be better or
here's ten ways here's ten ideas for
your podcast and and not just people all
the time throw ten guests at me but that
doesn't help me but here's 10 ways to
get here's 10 ways to get in touch with
them and that helps me a lot that's I've
met I've had a lot of meetings where
people have definitely offered value in
their emails and I said okay let's talk
more about this I love that concept I
think certainly to differentiate
yourself we've been talking a lot about
differentiating yourself how can you use
the uniqueness that you have as a person
and one of the most unique things that
we have as a as people is our networks
right like there's only you there is
precisely only you that knows all of the
people on the planet that you know and
now you know more because you know me
like that precisely you and that is it
so the power of networking when you look
at that is it is one way to out-compete
every single other person is to use your
network incorrectly and here's the thing
what people don't realize this is the
difference between linear power from
your network and exponential power from
your network so I can view my network as
me let's say I know a hundred people
yeah there's like draw a line between me
and all those hundred people that's a
hundred lines but now what if you draw
lines between all of them not even
including you so so let's say you give
your connections to your entire network
so now instead of a hundred lines
there's 10,000 lines because all hundred
are connected to all other hundred and
that's when you introduce to people that
you think could help each other they're
not going to forget who introduced them
you're still there even though it's a
little more
big you're still in that connection
there and that's the real power of your
network is when you give each each other
to each other and and and it's the same
thing with ideas you just kind of like
view an idea as a component of your
network give your ideas freely to people
who you think could use them and who
would be receptive to them and give it
in as a simple way as possible so
there's no work on their part so for
instance the very first time I got paid
for writing anything I wrote to a guy
who was a writer and I said here's 10 I
I love your articles but here's 10 ideas
for articles I would love to see you
write and I described the articles
completely so it would be almost trivial
for him to write the articles and and
and he wrote back and he said these are
great why don't you write the articles
and that was the very first professional
writing gig I ever had that's awesome
that's such a good example yeah as you
were talking about how you linking
people in together I was thinking about
kemal mutual friend of mine and yours
and Michael cashew who all of the
listeners will know CEO a brute strength
and I linked both of those in yesterday
as I just chatting to Michael about
something and he just came in my head I
was like [ __ ] you need to get kamal on
the brute strength podcast linked them
in and now now they're away Michael
I sent this is a cool one so add or Bray
on the show or berate Marcus is the most
difficult man and the planet to get hold
of by the way but his assistant managed
to get in with him and he's in Austin
and Michael my buddy CEO brute strength
in Austin and Michael's like kind of
into this self development space as well
and him and his missus addy they do a
lot of stuff and I was like it would be
awesome you should totally link up her
on it then they he went Michael went and
I think Michaels wife went and did a
podcast with obras ex mrs. Whitney and
now and I was like the exponential thing
I didn't even link those two people in
but because of the first iteration of
that and then you know it's is and it's
a good feeling as well it's it's it's
it's valuable because it makes you part
of the club it makes you part of the
scene that everyone else is trying to
build and it's really important that's
an important skill in today's society to
kind of not be real scarce about your
network like well I don't want him
knowing him I only want to know each
each of them like even the first time
you and I spoke I didn't know you were
gonna have I didn't know you knew Kemal
and I said oh you should have come on
your podcast like just having a reflex
of just anybody who can help anybody
else just don't hold back like it's a
world of abundance and and don't be
afraid of of losing connections by
giving them to someone else that's not
how it works you don't really give a
connection to someone else you copy the
connection and give the copy to someone
that's a beautiful way to put it look
James and we've been going for forever
I've taken up so much of your day but
it's uh it's been great I thank you so
much it's a great podcasters
you're a great interviewer and I was
really happy to come on it's been an
absolute pleasure if the listeners want
to find out more why should they go to
hustle you online I'll find out your
stuff check out my podcast the James
Altucher show will be linked in the show
notes below as well choose yourself on
Amazon you know what to do if you've
enjoyed the episode like share and
subscribe definitely go and check out
James's podcast man it's been awesome
thank you so much thank you so much
Chris I will talk to you soon
[Music]
you